new rule Daniel Howland the Texas fan
who got a tattoo of that color-changing
dress really needs a tortilla for our
wedding before period before he hits
another tattoo because his other tattoos
are new coke the choice of the next
generation myspace the social network of
tomorrow
and Bill Cosby is USA dad number one
forever mural Bill O'Reilly and Brian
Williams must co-host a new evening news
program called Eyewitness News
not I witness news this is Eyewitness
News where the two anchors take turns
describing events they saw in photos or
happen to other people watch Bill
O'Reilly in the studio throw to Bill
O'Reilly reporting from Syria who tosses
to Brian Williams who's live in Tokyo
who then throws back to the newsroom and
your host Brian Williams
Nowell after 30 years of trying Paul
McCartney has to admit that he should
stick to singing with white people
you'll get it later
anyway new old don't be upset if you
just found out that RadioShack went
bankrupt and they're no longer honoring
their gift cards be upset that someone
thought so little of you that they gave
you a new role North Korea's Kim Jong on
must admit that at this point he's just
daring someone to laugh at his haircut
so we can have them killed and also that
he just sits down in the barber chair
points to the brush and says make me
look like